alors je suis venu te dire endroit mais
kazimiyah mon vieux c'est pas encore le
roi va peut-être mais je suis tellement
triste de quitter nos amis est content
de partir en vacances que je ne peux pas
attendre plus pour dire au revoir
désigné je te comprends un peu quand on
s'en va on sait jamais très bien si on
est tristes ou si on est gay mais quand
même casimir c'est le jour où tous nos
amis partent en vacances n'est ce pas
alors tu vas pas alors leur gâcher leur
plaisir en ayant le cafard donc tu as
raison je vais partir sur la pointe des
pieds on s'entend pas pourtant pas comme
ça personne ne s'apercevra de rien 1
allez au revoir à françois et vivre
encore et casimir mon vieux nick casimir
de toute façon tu ne veux pas partir
maintenant julie m'a dit de te donner
rendez-vous ici elle veut que vous
partiez en vacances ensemble je veux
bien mais c'est vraiment parce que c'est
tel un vrai mieux je vais chercher mes
affaires entre la roue coulisses il est
parfait je lui dirai
ça y est c y et sortait il a disparu
c'est parti venu de
coventry
cadeau formidable on va la trouver ici
léonard mais qu'est ce que tu fais ici
mon vieux je viens je viens pour dire
moi aussi au revoir à mon ami casimir -
non julie tu as porté tous tes bagages
oui voilà commencé c'est tout ah oui je
n'ai pris que l'essentiel bien parfait
comme ça casimir sera rassuré monsieur
du sna oui bakhtaoui l'abandon à la
vessie chez à me regarder
elle est belle elle est balle un temps
superbe oui voici mon bouquet france pas
comment le trouvez-vous ils sont dont il
très très attention aux places le voilà
qui arrive oh la la
qu'est ce que tu veux dire
mes amis 12 experts venus lui souhaiter
bonne chance je remercie je suis revenu
et casimir nos vieux qu'est ce que c'est
que toutes ses valises genre ans et
quelques petits jouets il faut que je me
répète parce que j'ai encore plus grand
chariot de bagages
casimir tiens je te ra ceci c'est un
gâteau aux câpres et à la moutarde pour
son je crois que ça te plaira merci à
15h à casimir voilà ce sont des éclairs
au globull gars vous êtes très gentil
monsieur du souvenir si vous et voici
quelques fleurs pour toi mon petit
canard y aura au mazel scrutin mais
qu'il ne fallait pas
cette europe à une belle salade
[Musique]
alors
oui
vous en êtes fut
souvent de vieux oui oui je vais leur
dire merci
c'est s était le commandant d'une pente
me dis qu'il ya tellement de monde sur
le bateau qu'on ne peut pas prendre plus
de trois colis ouraga chacun on pouvait
quasiment comment vas tu faire le choix
va être très difficile casimir non je ne
crois pas je les trouve alors le gap ou
d'acteurs à pour surtout ne le
regrettera pas je vous tiens à porter
les éclairs de monsieur huysman alors je
suis très émue casimir est évidemment ni
rose de mademoiselle [ __ ] tu es trop
gentil mon petit canard hon nous guette
et vient maintenant casimir nous allons
tous accompagnés à trèbes ont aidé
à la maman et il en est pas question
pourquoi d'abord je déteste les adieux
sur les quais qu'ils soient de garou de
prends ça me donne envie de pleurer et
ensuite c'est ici que casimir devait
chanter sa chanson une dernière fois
avant de partir voilà
casimir tu va nous chanter ta chanson
volontiers
[Musique]
avec du thym chanson
imagine
sans mal
[Musique]
me rencontrer
soyez tout héros
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'amène casini
[Musique]
c'est la mère poule
ce
ce jouet de l'année si je suis allé ce
matin camille si j'aime la glace aux
anchois c'est mon choix et mon droit
avec une chanson
vous emmène dans notre xv e au pays du
bonheur tranquille
ces coupeurs montrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
abel asie
une
magie mais bon
je m'en jeu
lou biblique à
[Musique]
2006 mais mes quatre
enfants
[Musique]
imaginez
en même temps aux pigeons
m il
faire tomber
ne soyez pas terroriste
je suis le bon ce qui fait rire
m'appelle quasiment
[Musique]